I see I'm playing 1486 okay I'm not
gonna be zerk because that sign will
take a lot of energy out of me this will
be kind of more instructive so I'll try
and talk through my ideas III is usually
a signal that either wants to play a
collie or a stone wall let's try and be
as aggressive as possible so c5 aims to
put the pressure it also keeps my
options open I have a lot of different
ways of developing here
I could play an immediate g6 I could
take on d4 I think with c4 I can take
and if he takes back with pawn I play d5
and I'm guaranteeing a position where
he'll have an isolated pawn I should
note that we have actually transposed
into into caro-kann line this is
actually the town of attack and a pretty
common signature of this line is usually
a white we'll get an isolated pawn and
there's I think a few ways of playing
for black black and play 96 or
immediately six I'm gonna play a
positional g6 and yeah we'll try and
beat this guy with just like pure
positional chess let's develop this Evan
and usually the argument is that white
will have more space but black will have
a better con structure this castle
you know shamelessly advertised my
stream in the chat I'm streaming my
games if anyone is interested you go
make sure it looks ok looks decent 9595
is uh I don't think I've actually seen
this idea so early like usually white
will play Bishop d3 castle and then go
for a 95 so I'm wondering if there's a
way to punish white immediately and
probably the best approach is to finish
development something like like knight
c6 this can this can be played without
too much calculation and I'm basically
just putting the ball in White's courts
of challenging whether he wants to leave
his not in e5 or if he wants to take on
c6 if he takes on c6 I would just take
back and have better Center and that's
the sound of tea
I'll be right back
okay Bishop to e7 this is actually one
move I was looking forward to
I'm actually not sure if he had anything
better but maybe Knight takes c6 would
be interesting
there's some interesting calculations
there anyway I'm relatively pleased with
this position because he has lace at
pong I have a very solid block aid next
step will be just developing my bishop
and not running in into any stupid
tactics b6 I think I think should work
without too many problems if he takes on
d5 I take back with Knights and the key
is I don't want upon a black pawn to
land on d5 I want to keep either at
night or on our feet trades I want my
queen to land on d5 so I think b6 is uh
is very solid um no I just want to play
Bishop e7 next
okay this should be five this should be
seven it's actually very strange like he
hasn't castles at all
and sometimes when that happens there
will be tactics to exploit the king in
the center and well I'm realizing here
if he castles immediately there's a few
different tactical options for black one
of which is my Knight f4 which I could
play here
I think Knight f4 is just winning an
either for I win g2 there's also 90 X
III and Queen d5 but neither four seems
very direct and welcome eight xnv thanks
for commenting in the twitch chat I know
there's not too many viewers but I think
I I grab some by by shamelessly
advertising and in the tournament chats
so now I have a very pleasant option I
can take on g2 I can take on d4 taking
on g2 comes with check I think both both
of these moves should just be very
strong I'm kind of leaning towards
taking on d4 cuz I'm he's in he's in a
difficult situation and it's not
entirely clear what he should defend if
I took on g2 immediately it would be
very clear he would just move his king I
would have to think again but taking on
d4 I think keeps the pressure and keeps
it keeps a situation where he could make
more mistakes and there's a lot of thing
singing here G to pawn still hanging by
25s hanging if he moves his Knight
for example Knight back to f3 and then
his queen is lost after something like
93
just draw arrows to demonstrate 93 would
come with with check and then I would
take the Queen apex envy just started
playing chess and I'm having a lot of
trouble playing early game so playing
the opening of the game I think you mean
you have a set of openings you just kind
of memorize personally
there are hundreds upon hundreds of
variations that I've memorized but this
has taken years and years to kind of
develop and the opening is it's kind of
a different part of chess because a lot
of it has to do with memory but it's
also about kind of understanding which
types of structures that you want to go
into I think if you're just starting out
you want to maybe pick a few openings to
kind of gain experience with and it it
takes a lot of time in patients and also
persistence where if you're struggling
with one opening what you should do is
identify where you're having trouble
like if you play a game you you lose the
game quickly you want to go back find
the improvement or find what you can do
better next time and then keep the same
opening now there are kind of a set of
openings which I find easier to to play
I was about to play ghee for there if
I'm gonna demonstrate this with d41
hoping that I highly recommend if you're
just starting out you want something
simple is London with Bishop f4 and if
you have no clue about like specific
lines or what to memorize the one thing
you should know is a setup
III 903 bishop goes to d3 castle it's
one of the most basic setups you can
play and then depending what black does
like c3 or c4 and then this bike can
develop like this and
say most games if you're playing at
maybe a beginning level this will get
you by it will give you a very playable
position going into the middle game so
that's what I'll do and the London is
one of the few openings which a lot of
beginners like to play but it's still
very very very popular online GM level
I've studied it at a very high level so
they certain details and he wants us to
know but yeah
apex NV I hope that that gives you some
guidance and sometimes at the various
player 2 player I mean some players can
get by with playing any opening and then
they just focus on the middle game
strategy and tactics but one thing I
will say is probably at least 90% to 99%
of chess games are not determined and
opening so it's not necessarily the most
important area of the game that you want
to focus on at least starting out ok he
plays g5 I'm just gonna continue
developing actually a bit curious here
there's any like sort of immediate
tricks no there's occasionally like if
black through and c5 there's sometimes
ideas of Bishop take b8 Queen a for
check and then Bishop comes to b5 I've
had a game game like that once but it
requires black to play c5 Bishop b4 is
uh is interesting is its allowing Queen
a4 check which would force Knight to c6
I'm not sure how strong it is for white
but I have to calculate here
so when a4 check a knight c6 is forced
and then 95 next logical move
he has to defend the night cap late
Queen d7
can't really play Queen d6 either I'm
taking time here because if Queen eight
for a knight c6 95 is winning then I
just want to be sure of it
he could play 94 I have a feeling I'm
gonna win material at the end of the
line so okay we'll see what he does
sometimes what's more important than
kind of building up like your your
memorized opening lines is actually
building a pattern recognition which is
different because you're not you're not
memorizing like specific moves and
specific positions but you're you're
kind of familiar rising yourself with
different patterns and that moment with
like this should be four and this is
such a typical pattern in Queen pot
openings where where Queen a for a check
can be somewhat deadly so I think he's
suffering here I'm actually curious so
it like he could he could castle and if
I take on c6 he is Queen d7 now my one
hope is he's not watching the stream and
then hopefully he won't find that the
castling might actually be a fine move
for black
yeah if anyone else is watching the
stream and you guys have questions I
mean these games are are slow-paced
enough where I can answer and play this
guy actually might be watching this
dream because castling is is not the
easiest move to find but now I'm
actually realizing it might be more
complicated
it might takes you six Queen g7 C take
d5 might take d5 Bishop b5 a6
okay worst-case scenario I don't win
anything and I just have equal material
position with two bishops so we'll see
what happens Queen d7 good finds
I mean backup plan is just like Queen c2
or even like Bishop e2 okay let's let's
analyze seat 85-95 this should be five I
think it might take c3 so
okay so I guess the question is do I
want to move the Queen or move the
bishop
this is line that Bishop e2 Bishop takes
c6 between c2 and then he takes on c4
and he could just get away with winning
upon and if I I think we need to
immediately takes on c6
okay I'm I think I'm gonna play Bishop
e5 because if Bishop to Bishop to e5 if
he takes on c6 with the Queen we trade
Queens should be positional enough where
I can I'll have some advantage if he
takes with Bishop we can see - and like
the one concern I wanted the Jeep on
covered but I also want this line if he
takes takes his Bishop could take on g2
I would have ripped g1 and there's some
there's some pressure on the G file I'm
gonna play Bishop g5 or Bishop to g5 I
might be completely overthinking this
but okay
I mean it is a line where yeah if he
does get too greedy actually there's a
funny line if he takes on c4 I take on
c4 he takes on g2 I flare up to you one
he plays Bishop a4 I could take on e4 he
takes money for I would play rook to e7
King h8 and then like rook rook g6 is
inmates but rook take f7
kingi aids rook mmm now that I take the
Queen and I'm up I think I'm up at least
up on
I will admit that sometimes this is like
one of the biggest weaknesses of
stronger players is they they over
calculate and they take too much time
now this happens with like some of the
strongest players in the world and of
course he doesn't go into any of those
lines let's take on d5
apex NV I find that if I get paranoid if
I don't castle as soon as possible I end
up casting too early and get put in that
position is that a common mistake I have
to reread that if I don't castle as if I
don't castle as soon as possible I mean
usually it's not a mistake to Castle too
early I might depend on the specific
position usually what I've seen is
people make the mistake of not castling
early enough and that's when they get
into trouble for example the last game I
played my opponent just left his King in
the center and then there were all these
tactics I could use to exploit it so it
really depends but usually you can't go
wrong with castling too early but this
is another aspect of chess it's hard to
generalize there are certain rules we
can take kind of certain principles we
can follow but at the end of the day it
usually comes down to the unique
position and every position is different
so unfortunately I can't give a
necessarily clear answer but I think I
didn't answer the question that castling
too early is usually not a common
mistake let's play f3
Neph 3 has some positional goals
restricting the Knights also maybe
future fans of flying e4
I'm just play some quick improving moves
I have a cool idea here I would love it
if my queen was the one meeting the
battery on the h-file
or on the be the b1 h7 to agonal so I
would have some meeting possibilities
and I wanted to play Queen f2 Bishop e1
and then Queen back to C - but he's kind
of being annoying so here I'm debating
between Bishop f5 and Bishop e2 let's
play just about 5 of second guessing
myself just trying to figure out if if
his bishop is better than my bishop or
vice versa
okay thank you should be too the reason
for that is because usually if you have
the bishop here you don't want to trade
off a pair of Bishops especially if it's
not clear and the eventual plan is to
play Bishop d1 Bishop c2 and get the
bishop back to the good diagonal
I still have ideas of e4 as well
so usually when that's my opponent Stein
I don't know what to think about I'll
just like kind of look at what my
resources are before was a resource g 4h
for these might not be like the best
ideas but they are certainly worth
considering they should be one Bishop c2
and doing this sort of analysis will
give me a better idea of of what to look
for and what my what my possibilities
are also have some cool idea like king
h1 or of g1 and start pushing the Jeep
on let's start with Bishop to d1 really
the plan is just to just to improve
especially if he's not doing in anything
immediate let's not let him take
and of course this is a very standard
idea of pushing the queenside pause
it's time to lay e-4 comes with a threat
he can't he can't ignore it because I do
want to take on on d5 if he takes on you
for I take back and makes life a bit
more comfortable and then my bishop can
develop to f3 so if he wants to keep the
position closed you'd probably have to
move the Queen
but I think efore was a good move to at
least make him think try and figure out
what what the options are for black if
you play it's quite enough six oh I
think I just play Queen d2 and then go
for some a five idea at some point I
want to play I want to move my queen off
c2 it's really the bishop belongs on c2
I could play e5 I could play d5 but
probably just gonna have to use
intuition here let's play Bishop f3 just
not make any commitments just yet and I
think I'm threatening I thought I was
threatening e5 but he has 95
okay let's do this just gonna play quick
try and get back level time I've
completely forgot he could take on d5
and we got some Queen versus two rooks
ending if he takes on d5
well he can't take on d5 with at night
because pawn take and then for example
take take we trade on e1 at the very end
I have King f2 and then his his rook and
his Bishop would be hanging so if he
wants to go for this line he could take
with the bishop take take take take king
f2 and he has two rooks on a pawn for a
queen which is normally I would normally
be just off material for luck but I
think the two bishops are just so
powerful and I would have the pasty pod
so it would be an interesting line mm I
just want to reinforce everything it's
like we enough to keeping the rook on
you undefended
and sometimes positions like this you
don't want to like try and kill them
immediately you just want to keep things
solid and and just slowly but surely
improve also like poke around at them -
my my next move is gonna be a pokey move
like Queen g3 just see how he meets
threats of Bishop take aged six now I
have a pleasant time advantage so I
think the game has at least steering in
my favor
Queen a3 slightly annoying really Queen
d4 it's late windy for controlling the
center if he takes on a - I could try
and trap this Queen I also have Bishop
take h6 which looks decent
so I don't think there's too much to
talk about here it's just uh easy
they're losing on time over
I'm just getting a very bad position
already a very bad position
just wants to flag I guess okay real
quick let's try and figure out where he
went wrong
III thought Bishop before was a mistake
but I guess this line allows black to
survive with Queen d7 but I think I
think it still offered a Pleasant middle
game for me because because of the two
bishops and because I had more more
potential to just take over the center
with this f3 e4 idea but c-4 was kind of
annoying you know I kind of
underestimated this move I should
probably play Queen f2 first so that if
he plays c4 I could drop the bishop
either back to b1 or back to C to just
keep it on a good diagonal anyway got to
this position you know I think it was
just kind of a slow grind after this
felt like I was in pretty good control
I think this line would have been really
interesting if he takes me open up the
analysis board if he takes here I take
he takes tick tick here
I just saw the computer evaluation it's
it's giving a big plus for whites but I
know if I necessarily trust that maybe
it makes sense like his works can't
really penetrates and the deep hunt
could be really annoying that still
would have been interesting anyway um
yeah I think that was a smooth game
hopefully whoever was watching picked up
some some stuff I see someone's
commenting on the chat get a superstar I
don't know what Nick loping is saying
I'll try and take that as a compliment
okay how long is this tournaments hour
and 46 minutes I'm gonna take a break
and stop the stream I hope for those who
are watching I think there's a five
people for who are not me
I hope you guys enjoyed that feel free
to follow me on Twitch or leach s if you
want to see more and I will be back at
some point in the future
bye